[Music]
what I love about you is that you can do
so much in the music world I mean you're
performing tonight with Carrie Underwood
yeah very happy about that
very excited and it's a powerful message
in the song so we want to make sure
everybody here what does the song mean
to you it means everything because
anybody that's going through any type of
struggle or people that need positive
motivation and inspiration that's
literally what this song is about
everybody is a champion you know in
their minds and at hearts and sometimes
you go through difficulties and you have
to remind yourself how much of a
champion you are here you sort of took a
break from the spotlight after her
accident every day I feel a little more
a little more back to normal what has it
been like to work with her and to sort
of support her through this just being
patient because everybody has you know
like I said everybody has difficulties
and she's definitely one like I would
say about 95% better I'm sure you'll be
able to ask her that when she gets here
but she's very strong anybody who has
strong will strong minded they'll be
able to bounce back people to take away
from the performance what kind of
feelings do you want to emot-- I'll take
the words of the song that's just if you
listen to the words then you'll see
exactly what you're supposed to take
away from
[Music]
[Applause]